[Music]  I'm gonna do an ET fast 5 this is just  you answering five questions very  quickly what is the sexiest quality that  a woman can have to you confidence what  is the biggest turnoff like cynicism  like like- I'm with you on that what's a  good first date I would love to be able  to go on a first date with someone that  like proves that you can have fun with  that person so if it's like I don't know  like something like how does it work  like maybe like bungee jumping or  skydiving obviously that's like a very  like far-fetched first date I don't  think you might die would you ever date  a fan I don't think so  I don't know maybe if the circumstances  were right what is the weirdest thing a  fan has done to you or for you to this  day someone made a blanket with all of  my faces on it and I was incredibly  flattered by it with like my bachelor  picture and like my facebook profile  pictures over here and then like some of  my Instagram pictures down here  you